was able to meet
the passing of a giant among Statesmen
marked with a few solitary carnations at
the foundation that he ran very ill
these last few months but still aware
and deeply troubled by what was
happening in Ukraine who've been working
with him for so many years Pavel
palashenko worked as Gorbachev's
translator for 37 years Always by his
side in moments where history was made
regarded the whole
Evolution negative evolution of the
relationship
uh as a tragedy but really a tragedy for
him because among other things you know
he is of part Ukrainian descent
his wife is either
was either fully Ukrainian or half
Ukrainian you know he made a statement
calling for an early end of the
hostilities on the 26th of February
and after that he chose not to comment
and particularly given his health
situation
from the Russian president a telegram on
the Kremlin website expressing his deep
condolences to the family saying
Gorbachev had a huge impact on global
history
the official response from the Russian
state has been fairly muted it's hardly
surprising given Mikhail Gorbachev's
mixed Legacy here and also the Colossal
differences between him and Vladimir
Putin one man intent on trying to build
trust and better relations between East
and West the other seemingly now at
least intent on ripping them apart
A Chorus of Praise from Western leaders
for the man who ended the Cold War
Russian talk shows though dismissive of
the press commentaries from those they
call Russia's enemies when the picture
back home is so murky they say
and certainly no love lost here for
Gorbachev across the lake from the
cemetery where he'll be buried
he changed things for the worse he split
the country lost a lot
they destroyed everything nothing good
to see now we have a good president a
real one
actually you know the way
many people misunderstand him it's not
Gorbachev's problem it's a Russia's
problem because I think that in order to
really have a path to the Future it will
have to come to
a proper appreciation of kobachev
a moral voice lost to Russia he will be
buried beside his beloved wife Raisa
this coming Saturday with a farewell
ceremony Russia's president has yet to
confirm if he'll attend
Dana McNay Sky News Moscow